[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui on est on produit donc
en termes de débit donc du 90 normaux
mètre cube heure
donc ça c'est une moyenne sur l'année
quoi en termes de d'énergie on peut
alimenter je pense au minimum au moins
3000 foyers
sont exploitation comme la nôtre
[Musique]
le gaz à vague alimenter un moteur qui
produit l'électricité qui est injecté
sous le réseau EDF donc 150 kw/h
et après tout le moteur fait de la
chaleur et la chaleur produite par le
moteur
elle permet de chauffer donc le
digesteur de chauffer mes poulailler
chauffer l'eau chaude sanitaire débattre
de l'élevage mais aussi de ma maison et
le chauffage aussi
à peu près 10 ans d'âge maintenant on a
commencé par des balbutiements avec
voilà aujourd'hui dire qu'elle soit elle
est mature elle évolue sans arrêt on a
pas mal de paramètres qui fait que du
coup est vas-y c'est sur les coûts de
construction qui sont qui sont énormes
aujourd'hui sur les coûts de l'énergie
qui pour faire marcher l'installation et
sur les coûts de rachat électrique et
gaz qui sont pas à la hauteur de du
marché actuel
[Musique]